so Ukraine is now demanding a lot more
money from the United States in fact
more money than its entire pre-war
budget consisted of obviously members of
both parties in Congress will grant that
request because securing Ukraine's
border is their top priorities as Mitch
McConnell George W bush agrees nothing's
more important than Ukraine
certainly not our Southern border which
remains completely open Congressman Andy
Biggs who represents the State of
Arizona was at the Border in Yuma a few
days ago here's some of what he saw
after they've crossed the reservation
we'll walk down up to this dirt road and
they come up here CBP it tells them all
to sit down they're going to wait now
hours before buses to come and process
these individuals are taken to the Yuma
processing center and what we would say
military age young men single men
over there in that area so there's lots
lots going on here at in the Yuma border
so why is this happening super simple
Joe Biden opened the border and hasn't
closed it why is he doing that probably
a lot of reasons all of them Sinister
anti-democratic and in fact evil this is
a crime
the United Nations just declared that
the U.S Mexico border is the deadliest
in the world in the world in the United
States welcome to Third World America
multiple Texas counties declared today
that what's happening at the border
constitutes an invasion because it does
Andy Biggs as we told you represents
Arizona in the United States Congress he
joins us tonight Congressman thanks so
much for coming on so members of
Congress from Texas call this an
invasion do you think that's fair
yeah it's it's fair it's accurate
Arizona's attorney general has said the
same and uh that what you're seeing from
the videos when I was down there Tucker
that is a regular routine and uh we met
people from Georgia uh all kinds of
Latin American countries uh African
nations China India that happens every
morning I mean that was about four about
four to four Thirty in the morning that
day and uh it's it's non-stoppable
because we've basically said come in and
you ask him why are you here and they'll
say Biden told us to come in that is an
invasion that is an invasion so this
will completely change America in a
democracy the citizens get to decide
what kind of country they want to live
in now the bite Administration is it'll
never be the same country ever millions
of new people all illegal so like why is
this not a crime that's being prosecuted
why isn't the president being impeached
the president being impeached for this
well I think it should be I think uh
they because they've deliberately when I
say they I mean President Biden Kamala
Harris secretary mayorkas they have
deliberately stopped enforcement under
title eight which is the immigration and
nationalization act and then you also
have uh title 42 that they're they're
hedging on they're not enforcing the law
they're not allowing ice to actually uh
remove people and they're actually
surreptitiously providing a de facto
amnesty program to a lot of people that
they're catching releasing to me that's
a violation of the law and it's
dangerous to this country because I mean
we could talk about terrorist crime we
could talk about the the drugs that are
coming in we could talk about the danger
to the people that are coming in
illegally
but the guy in Viking horns is a threat
to democracy you know Biden and my
Orchestra are threat to democracy real
threat I would say Congressman Andy
Biggs I appreciate it from Arizona good
to see you